today we're gonna talk about natural
desiccated thyroid and why some people
feel worse when they take it and I'm
talking about like armored thyroid or
nature troy'd or NP thyroid these
contain porcine or Pig thyroid extracts
so the question we want to look at is
why would someone feel worse with
something more natural versus something
more synthetic like synthroid now it
could be that these products have some
additional ingredients that you are
reacting to because they do add things
like dextrose corn starch cellulose to
these products and you could be reacting
to those however if your reaction is
extreme fatigue or the flu-like symptoms
chances are the reason for that is that
you have Hashimoto's which is an
autoimmune condition and the great
majority of people that have
hypothyroidism have Hashimoto's and
what's happening is you have the thyroid
gland and you have antibodies that are
attacking itself so it's almost as if
you have a allergy to your own thyroid
gland and these antibodies are just
keeping the thyroid inflamed and that is
causing if I were to be depressed
alright so the question is what can you
do about this at your action personally
if I had the problem I would switch to
synthroid which is a synthetic t4
because that would reduce the reaction
number one and I would search out a
product called thyrotropin PMG this is
thyroid extract without the hormones and
what I would do is I would take one of
these tablets before bed okay because it
might make you a little bit tired you're
just taking a small amount maybe you
might need to take even a half of a
tablet so it just creates a very very
mild reaction but you're going to sleep
so you're not going to really feel
anything you just probably gonna sleep
deeper and I would take a small amount
of this over a longer period of time
maybe about one to two months and that
will help you to deplete these anybody's
over a period of time so here's your
esophagus
here's your stomach so this thyrotropin
PMG gets swallowed goes in the stomach
these antibodies now go hey what's this
in your stomach so it goes after the
thyroid extract in your stomach it
leaves the thyroid alone so now the
thyroid doesn't have to be inflamed
anymore okay
so you're getting rid of the
inflammation because these antibodies
are attacking a decoy in the stomach so
maybe will you do you start off with a
half of a tablet for a week and then go
up to a tablet for a week and see how it
goes if you have no reaction maybe you
go to two tablets and maybe even three
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to deplete your antibody Reserve
and decrease the inflammation around the
star right so it can start to work
better then after a period of a couple
of months reintroduce this and see if
you have the same reaction and also
realize that if you add in their healthy
ketosis okay and in a minute fasting the
need for thyroid hormones will go down
so that will improve things plus the
intermittent fasting will drop the
inflammation as well you may also want
to add some vitamin D in there because
vitamin D is very very important for all
types of autoimmune conditions alright
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications